the water in mississippi's largest city
is undrinkable do not drink the water i
want to be clear
please do not drink the water 150 000
residents of jackson the state capital
cannot drink the water cannot reliably
shower flush their toilets or battle
their city's fires governor tate reeves
on tuesday declared a state of emergency
one with no end in sight i can't give
you a time frame as to when we will be
pushing out
safe drinking water
days of torrential rains have swollen
the pearl river mixing sewage and
drinking water and overwhelming the
city's main water treatment plant
causing it to fail with the city unable
to afford the repairs the state is
offering emergency funding this gets
into quite possibly the billions of
dollars
and so that is far beyond the city of
jackson's reach to be able to accomplish
that on our own
long time jackson resident bernard smith
saw it coming and stocked up i always
try to stock up
on water supplies because that's stuff
that don't spoil
in any instances when you know you're in
a zone where this happens
you don't just all of a sudden you you
add to your supply they always told me
a snake can't fight you if you see it
first
jackson's population is largely black a
quarter live in poverty it's one of many
u.s cities suffering water supply
problems and until it can restore its
water treatment plant and fill its aging
pipes residents will have to make do
with boiled water bottled water and
plenty of patience john hendren al
jazeera